le ministre doit impérativement être au
ministère à 18h30 et moi je dois
impérativement être à la Conférence des
présidents à 18h donc voilà on va
essayer d'être assez rapide monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
réunis pour l'examen du volet
environnemental du projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 avec les deux
principaux avec la mission deux
principaux protagoniste chargé du
pilotage budgétaire de la mission
écologie et Christophe Béchu le ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des
territoires vague de chaleur sécheresse
d'ampleur inédite inondation et
précipitation torrentielle érosion
contière incendie de forte intensité
dépérissement des forêts les effets du
changement climatique sont ressentis
avec acité par nos concitoyens à côté
des inégalités et du pouvoir d'achat le
rapport annuel sur l'état de la France
du C a souligné que l'écoanxiété est une
préoccupation majeure des Français des
politiques publiques ambitieus et
volontaire en matière climatique et
environnementale sont plus que jamais un
impératif impératif pour adapter notre
pays à la hausse sans précédent des
températures d'ici la fin du siècle le
gouvernement a pris acte de la nouvelle
donne en instaurant un secrétariat
général à la planification écologique
pour promouvoir une approche globale de
la
transversalité dans l'action
interministérielle et des politiques à
la cohérence renforcée c'est une
démarche que nous saluons car nous avons
toujours considéré que l'environnement
n'était pas une politique sectorielle
mais avait vocation est prise en compte
de toutes les politiques nous avons
d'ailleurs plusieurs motifs de
satisfaction à l'analyse de ce projet de
loi inverdissement du budget de l'État
grâce à la baisse des dépenses
défavorables à l'environnement une
augmentation significative des moyens
consacrés à la mission ainsi qu'un
renforcement du du schéma d'emploi du
ministère et des opérateurs sous tutelle
sans oublier la hausse du fond vert de
500 millions d'euros pour décliner
territorialement les ambitions ce projet
de loi de finance veut une réponse
budgétaire au multiples défis de la
transition qu'il a euh qu'il s'agisse de
la décarbonation qu'il s'agisse de la
reconquête de la biodiversité de la
souverainetéc énergétique ou encore du
développement des mobilités
euh le le le défi de la
territorialisation des politiques
environnementales reste à relever car
les élus locaux sont toujours
insuffisamment associés pour que
coélaborer les chemins de la transition
avec les habitants l'impact des
activités économiques industrielles doit
être d sans pénaliser bien sûr la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
l'atteinte de nos objectifs à la
sobriété foncière n'a toujours pas
trouvé son modèle financier et son
modèle social la prévention de et
l'indemnisation des risques naturels
majeurs doit changer d'échelle pour
anticiper des événements majeur et
l'impossibilité d'assurer certains
risques la résilience hydrique doit
encore être renforcée pour faire face à
des étés où l'eau vient à manquer dans
les cours d'eau mais également au
robinet ces défis ne sont pas que
budgétaires il repose tout autant sur la
cohérence de l'action de l'État et de la
coordination des efforts de tous les
acteurs sur ce point j'aimerais
connaître votre méthodologie et vos
stratégies de conviction pour allier vos
collègues ministres au bien fondés des
politiques clim climatiques et
environnementales ambitieuse si l'action
publique ne saurait se ranger uniquement
sous la bannière de l'environnement
comment peut-on limiter autant que faire
ce peut les effets néfastes sur le
climat et la biodiversité des autres
politiques publiques quelle est votre
réponse climato cynisme qui semble se
développer au niveau international
comment faire de l'environnement une
grande cause nationale qui survive non
seulement aux alternances politiques
mais également au poids croissant de la
dette publique et à toutes les autres
priorités publiques également légitimes
au-delà de ces questions de méthode mes
intergégations portent sur le principe
des copes régionales imaginer dans le
but de territorialiser les mesures de
planification écologique à une échelle
plus fine et d'associer les
collectivités chefs de fil en la matière
pourriez-vous nous préciser ce que le
gouvernement attend de ses concertations
parfois critiqué par les exécutifs
régionaux comme trop descendant et la
manière dont il envisage et prépare les
sessions de travail quelles traductions
concrètes sont à espérer au termes des
échanges et des débats entre les élus
locaux et
l'État dans le cadre comment maximiser
l'effet levier du fond vert dans les
territoire et faire en sorte que les
sommes àouées au maire permettent
réellement de déclencher des décisions
d'investissement pour préparer
l'adaptation des territoires pouveznous
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur la
pérennité de ce fond vert pour les
années à venir ce fond a-t-il vocation à
devenir la caisse de mutualisation
budgétaire des dépenses en faveur de la
transition écologique je ne serais pas
plus long je souhaitais simplement
amorcer le dialogue avec ces quelques
préliminaires avant de laisser la parole
au commissairire et ils sont h pour les
traditionnelles séries de questions
réponses monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse la parole merci monsieur le
Président merci pour votre présence
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
puis merci de me permettre de répondre à
vos questions je vais essayer de vous
imiter monsieur le Président je ne mlève
pas au-dessus de ma condition mais je je
vais néanmoins calquer ma prise de
parole sur la vôre pour qu'elle soit
courte et pour laisser un maximum de
temps aux questions tant la nature de
ces questions peut être diverse et si je
vous emmène dans un tunnel qui consiste
à décrire par le menu les 10 milliards
d'euros d'autorisation d'engagement
prévu l'année dernière l'année prochaine
pardon ou si je commence à vous faire un
abécédaire je mettrai trop de temps à
arriver aux ZF au ZRR et aux an qui
peut-être intéresse un certain n d'entre
vous et dans la première lettre me
conduirait à trop retarder le moment où
je les évoque ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que nous sommes en train
d'examiner le PLF il y a des mesures qui
ne sont pas dans ce PLF qui par
définition feront l'objet de texte ou de
mesures spécifiques parce que la
transition écologique c'est bien sûr une
question de moyens budgétaire ça a été
objectivé par le rapport pisaniféri mais
c'est aussi une question d'état d'esprit
et de volonté et je réponds tout de
suite à votre première question sur
l'interministériel les deux leviers
principaux pour faire en sorte de
changer d'échelle et de braquer ou plus
exactement les trois c'est la formation
nous l'avons engagé pour les 25000
principes au cadre de l'État et
énormément de cabinets se sont penchés
sur des fresques du climat à leur
échelle comprendre les enjeux et
disposer des éléments de c'est la
planification le fait que nous ayons un
secrétariat général qui soit rattaché à
Matignon et pas seulement un ministre de
la transition écologique qui s'agite
pendant que ses collègues continuent
dans leur couloir et tr et c'est ma
méthode chiffrer le coût de
l'inaction on regarde parfois ce que ça
nous coûte de faire des choses mais on
ne regarde jamais ce que ça coû de ne
rien faire et si je prends un exemple
très simple qui est la sécheresse 2022
le coût c'est 2 milliards et demi ça
aider à convaincre qu'il fallait
augmenter le budget des agences de l'eau
de 475 millions d'euros par an pour
améliorer la résilience lutter contre
les fuites faire en sorte de prémunir
une partie des difficultés ce budget il
est porteur je l'ai dit de 10 milliards
c'est une ha de 15 % des moyens du
ministère 10 milliards d'autorisation
d'engagement mais j'insiste sur ce
chiffre parce qu'il ne faut pas
seulement regarder les crédits de
paiement en particulier sur le plan
ferroviaire on sait que la première
année vous ne faites que les études et
donc que les sommes à engager sont
faibles et donc ce qui compte c'est bien
ce que vous initiez de façon globale
dans ces 10 se sont pilotés par mon pôle
ministériel trois sont à l'extérieur je
pense par exemple au crédit sur la forêt
qui peuvent relever du ministère de
l'Agriculture je pense au crédit pour
l'immobilier de l'État pour que l'État
soit lui-même en situation de rénover
ses bâtiment et pas seulementinciter les
autres à le faire deuxième point que je
souhaite mettre en avant dans ce budget
ce sont les postes pour mener le combat
contre les règlements climatiques il
faut des femmes et des hommes le pôle
ministériel de la transition écologique
est celui qui a perdu le plus d'emplois
que ce soit en interne ou au travers de
ces opérateurs tout gouvernement
confondu depuis 20 ans en
pourcentage l'année prochaine c'est 760
créations net de poste pour le pôle
ministériel que je dirige après pour la
première fois une stabilité que j'avais
obtenu en
2023 et dans ces 760 une part est pour
le ministère central une part est pour
les opérateurs y compris des opérateur
emblématique je pense à l'ofb je pense à
Météo France pour lequel nous créons 25
postes l'année prochaine après en avoir
créé 23 cette année et je pourrais
évidemment égrainer les choses laadem le
serema et cetera je m'arrête là je ne
fais pas un inventaire à la prévre
préventif les grands domaines sur
lesquels nous renforçons nos moyens
budgétaires c'est d'abord la rénovation
la rénovation énergétique elle un mérite
c'est qu'elle est bonne pour la fin du
monde et pour la fin du mois et qu'elle
génère des emplois qui ne sont pas
délocalisables 1 Millard 600 millions
d'euros supplémentaires dont une part
fléchée vers le logement social de
manière à pouvoir accélérer des
rénovations qui soient des rénovations
globales le tout accompagné d'une
refonte de ma prime renve autour de deux
piliers un pilier performance et un
pilier efficacité que je tiens que je
suis évidemment capable de détailler
devant vous et quelques autres sujets
complémentaires en matière de logement
euh
le la volonté de faire en sorte de nous
appuyer sur le bâtier existant nous
conduit également à faciliter la
transformation de bureaux en logement je
vous rappelle que c'est 3 millions et
demi de mèes carrés pour la seule région
parisienne et qui parfois se heurte à
des dispositifs qui ne sont pas des
problèmes seulement budgétaires ou
fiscaux mais des problèmes
réglementaires l'autre grand domaine
dans lequel nous avançons c'est bien
entendu celui des mobilités vous
retrouverez évidemment sans surprise
dans le budget le plan vélo doté de ces
200 millions d'euros à au 50 de 2018 et
au Z0 des années précédents 2018 vous
retrouverez le verdissement du parc
automobile avec la nouveauté qui va être
déployer dans les prochains jours qui
est le leasing social à 100 € qui se
déploierera au titre de l'année 2024 et
qui permettra conformément à la promesse
du candidat de pouvoir faire en sorte
que un certain nombre de Français entre
20 et 25000 sans doute en 2024 puissent
bénéficier de ce dispositif je vous
rappelle et ça d'ailleurs fait partie
des interpellations de cette maison
l'année dernière que nous réservons C à
des voitures qui sont construites en
France ou en Europe pour ne pas utiliser
l'argent public pour soutenir la filière
automobile chinoise ce qui entraîne le
fait que nous ayons une première marche
en terme de disponibilité moins
importante que ce que nous aurions pu
souhaiter ensuite c'est la biodiversité
dans quelques jours avant la fin du mois
de novembre nous présenterons avec Sarah
lairy la stratégie nationale de
biodiversité quand on parle d'écologie
on a tendance aujourd'hui à se
concentrer sur le climat pour des
raisons évidentes c'est qu'il y a le GC
et c'est qu'on a un indicateur qui est
simple à retenir que sont les tonnes de
CO2 l'érosion de biodiversité qui est
plus complexe à mesurer parce qu'elle
agrège des quantités d'indicateurs et
même s'il y a une sorte de GC de la
biodiversité qui a baisse il est plus
complexe de suivre ces sujets mais ce
sont 800 millions d'euros qui sont
consacrés et le Conseil national de la
biodiversité qui s'est penché sur la
stratégie du gouvernement 78 membres a
émis un avis avec zéro avis négatif je
le signale ça n'est pas le cas de figure
le plus probable au sein du ministère de
l'écologie quand le gouvernement
présente des dispositifs 70 votes pour 8
abstentions je tenais évidemment à le
souligner augmentation des moyens des
agences de l'eau conformément à ce qui a
pu être indiqué stratégie nationale de
la biodiversité des crédits
complémentaires également pour le fond
chaleur 300 millions d'euros pour l'ADEM
là aussi vous aviez en séance l'année
dernière interrogé la trajectoire nous
vous avions répondu que c'était grâce à
la trésorerie de l'ADEM que il pourrait
y avoir 800 millions d'engagés là où il
y avait que 500 millions de budget cette
trésorerie ayant été mise à contribution
nous augmentons les crédits à la hauteur
que vous souhaitiez enfin vous m'avez
interrogé sur le fond vert il est
pérennisé et il est augmenté il passe de
2 milliards à 2 milliards et demi
d'euros et je tiens à vous dire que la
hausse à disposition des préfets est
plus élevée que ce que ces 500 millions
d'euros peuvent laisser présager de
manière faciale la réalité du fond vert
c'est que c'était 1 milliard et demi à
la main des préfets et 1 demi milliard
de recyclage de l'excédent de l'année
2022 de CVAE par rapport à la
trajectoire triénale permettant de
calculer le niveau de de compensation de
TVA prenant place dans le panier de
recettes des collectivités
territoriales nous maintenons un fond
qui passe à 2 milliards et demi qui
désormais est à la main des préfets sans
appel à projet sans appel à
manifestation d'intérêt et qui a
rencontré un succès en 2023 au-delà de
nos espérances je suis dors et déjà en
mesure de vous dire que ce seront plus
de 8000 communes qui bénéficieront d'une
subvention dans le cadre du fond vert
générant l'équivalent de 10 milliards
d'euros d'investissement un titre ou un
autre dans la transition écologique pas
très loin des estimations de i forc
chiffrant à 12,5 la part que les
collectivités devraient prendre sur une
part globale de 33 milliards dans le
cadre du rapport Pisani ferie vous
m'avez interrogé sur la diplomatie
environnementale et donc sur ce qui nous
attend dans les prochaines
semaines je suis tenté de vous dire que
en matière d'environnement pour
paraphraser un
théologien nous devons faire comme si
tout dépendait de nous et de nous
uniquement et donc nous concentrer sur
ce que nous pouvons faire à l'échelle de
la France et parfois nous rappeler que
beaucoup de choses dépendent
malheureusement de la façon dont les
choses s'agence sur le plan mondial les
chiffres publiés aujourd'hui sur la
progression des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre à l'échelle mondiale témoignent
du chemin qui reste à parcourir à
l'échelle de la planète là où notre pays
pour une année supplémentaire continue à
baisser ses émissions et nous avons un
premier semestre historique de baisse
d'émission puisqueaprès la moyenne à
plus de 2 % de ces 6 dernières années
nous sommes sur une trajectoire à 4,7 %
sur les deux premiers trimestres de
l'année
2023 correspondant au doublement que
devrions atteindre pour être dans le bon
rythme conformément à la planification
vous m'avez interrogé sur la façon
d'embarquer le pays et ensuite sur les
coopes régionales et je vais vous
répondre en une fois sur ces deux sujets
nous avons en matière d'écologie la
montée de deux types de
populisme un climatocepticisme qui n'a
pas disparu qui trouve une belle
résurgence sur les réseaux sociaux de
gens qui expliquent qu'il n'y a pas de
problème de sécheresse parce qu'il pleut
ou qui a pas de problème de chaleur
parce qu'il y a une journée où il a fait
froid et qui prend parfois une autre re
forme qui consiste globalement à se
demander si nous n'en faisons pas trop
et à l'inverse vous avez un discours qui
consiste à laisser dire que nous ne
ferions rien et qui je le considère
comme tel est une forme de
climatodéfétisme et qui dit que si on ne
fait pas tout c'est comme si on faisait
rien si on laisse une route se réaliser
dans le pays c'est qu'on fait pas de
planification écologique et si on
n'interdit pas les jets c'est la preuve
que nous n'avons aucune ambition
environnementale si on n'est pas capable
de sortir de ce type de posture qui dans
les deux cas sont des impasses on oublie
que la plupart de nos concitoyens vous
l'avez dit en amont aujourd'hui ce qui
les contrarie ce qui leur pollue la vie
ce qui les inquiète pour
l'avenir ce sont ces temps incertains
ces multiplications de catastrophes
c'est les conséquences de ce qui s'est
passé dans la vzuie ou dans le Pas de
Calais bien plus que les perspectives de
mettre en place des dispositifs qui les
protègeront même si nous avons vocation
à continuer à les assouplir embarquer le
pays ça veut dire sortir de ces postures
et ne pas les laisser en quelque sorte
les extrêmes monopoliser ce ce débat et
être capable de montrer qu'il y a un
chemin dans lequel écologie et économie
riment dans lequel l'écologie n'est pas
le prétexte pour taxer ou pour interdire
mais une manière de défendre notre
identité et notre souveraineté et une
façon plus large d'insister sur le fait
que c'est une défense de nos modes de
vie de la capacité que nous aurons à
laisser à nos enfants un monde qui soit
le plus vivable possible c'est mon
obsession le modeste moyen que j'ai
trouvé a été d'entamer un tour de France
je suis rendu à Sep débats avec des
citoyens dans des salles jamais moins de
250 personnes jamais moins de 2h de de
réunion avec des questions aussi
diverses que les éoliennes offshore les
passoirs énergétiques la mise en place
des ZFE la complexité du zan quand il y
a des élus et puis des sujets de tous
les jours sur un gérant de station de
lavage parce qu'il peut pas travailler à
cause d'un arrêté sécheresse un
agriculteur qui s'interroge sur les
injonctions contradictoires qu'il y a au
titre de la viande et du stockage dans
les prairies les difficultés enfin bref
je vais pas vous faire l'article vous
connaissez ces sujets par cœur vous les
rencontrez dans vos départements vous en
êtes des porte-voies fidèles quand vous
avez l'occasion de vous exprimer dans
l'hémicycle et je me réjouis de répondre
aux quelques questions sur lesquelles
vous déciderez de cibler vos
interventions merci monsieur le ministre
je va donner la parole à Pascal Martin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre rapporteur des crédits sur la
prévention des risques ma première
question portera sur les moyens dédiés à
l'inspection des installations classé
pour la protection de l'environnement en
2022 dans le cadre d'un rapport
d'information au titre du droit de suite
de la commission d'enquête lubisol
j'avais alerté sur les engagements non
tenu par l'État suite à l'incendie de
cette usine rouanaise en 2019 le
gouvernement s'était engagé à augmenter
de 50% les contrôles de site ICPE d'ici
2022 pour atteindre 27000 contrôles par
an en 2022 seul 22800 contrôles ont été
effectués l'objectif n'est pas atteint
prant acte de cette situation le projet
de loi de finance pour
2024 repousse cet objectif de 27000
contrôles à 2027 permettez-moi Monsieur
le Ministre d'être interrogatif sur la
capacité du gouvernement à atteindre cet
objectif en 2027 les effectifs réels de
l'inspection reste stable en raison me
semble-t-il d'un manque d'attractivité
d'une part malgré la création d'une
cinquantaine de postes depuis 2020
l'inspection est également confrontée à
un nouveau défi l'adaptation au
changement de procédure de la loi du 23
octobre 2023 relative à l'industrie
verte qui exige et c'est une nouveauté
dans le cadre de l'examen de
l'autorisation environnementale un
dialogue approfondi entre porteur de
projet et administration en amont du
dépôt de dossier comment Monsieur le
Ministre expliquez-vous ce report
d'objectif des contrôles à 2027 quels
moyen allez-vous consacrer d'ici 2027 à
la monter en puissance des contrôles
ICPE je souhaite également vous
interroger sur le bilan des plans de
prévention des risques technologiques
autrement appelés PPRT créé il y a
maintenant 20 ans suite à l'accident de
l'usine ADF pour protéger les
populations situées à proximité des
sites industriels l'association
amaris qui réunit les collectivités
accueillant sur leur territoire des
activités générant des risques
industriels majeurs dresse dans un
rapport récent de septembre 2023 un
bilan mitigé du dispositif faute de
financement adéquat et par manque
d'information 75% des logements privés
exposés ne font pas l'objet de travaux
de mise en sécurité à ce jour et
seulement 62 % des mesures foncière
d'expropriation
ou de délaissement ont été réalisés dans
un contexte de réindustrialisation
nécessaire pour notre souveraineté comme
pour la transition écologique la
protection des riverins conditionnera
l'acceptabilité locale des nouveaux
projets
industriels deè question donc
partagez-vous le constat d'Amaris
soulignant que les PPRT n'ont pas
atteint globalement leur objectif enfin
3è
question sujet particulièrement et
malheureusement d'actualité le risque
inondation l'année dernière dans le
cadre de l'avis budgétaire sur les
crédits relatifs à la prévention des
risques j'avais insisté sur la nécessité
dans le contexte du dérèglement
climatique de donner une priorité aux
mesures de prévention du risque
inondation j'avais ainsi proposé par
amendement de sécuriser l'attribution de
15 millions d'euros dédié au
renforcement de l'accompagnement des
collectivités territoriales dans les
actions de prévention proposition qui
malheureusement n'a pas été retenue dans
le texte
définitif après la tempête Alex en 2020
le risque inondation il n'est pas
nécessaire d'insister est de nouveau sur
le devant de la scène aujourd'hui avec
les les événements notamment vous y avez
fait allusion monsieur le ministre dans
le département du Pas decalais notre
commission d'ailleurs organisera un
déplacement que je conduirai jeudi 23
novembre afin d'exprimer notre
solidarité avec ce territoire durement
touché et et afin d'observer la réponse
des services de l'État et surtout
d'entendre les habitants les
collectivités territoriales et acteurs
économiques dans ce projet de loi de
finance à l'issue de la première lecture
à l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
a retenu un amendement sur le risque
inondation qui prolonge pour 2 ans
supplémentaires
l'expérimentation mieux reconstruire
après inondation je m'en félicite à la
lumière de la catastrophe naturelle en
cours et à la suite des annonces du
président de la République du 14
novembre dernier Monsieur le Ministre
d'autres amendements au projet de
finance 2024 sont-ils prévus afin de
renforcer la prévention du risque
inondation je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Guillaume
chevrolier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre en tant que
rapporteur pour avis paysage eau et
biodiversité et élu de la Mayenne
département de bocage par excellence
jeis aborder la question des ha on
estime que plus des 2/ers du linéire des
ha ont disparu en France depuis le le
milieu du siècle dernier cette
disparition silencieuse et lourde
d'impact pour les territoires et est
difficile à quantifier selon l'Office
français de la la biodiversité environ
11500 kmè de haie disparaissent chaque
année pour 3500 replantés les services
écosystémiques rendus par les sont
pourtant de premier ordre certains
estiment qu'elles peuvent être comparées
à des tours de Babel écologique en
servant non seulement de refuge mais
également de réserves de nourriture de
corridor de biodiversité
de régul des flux hydriques autrement
dit de ralentissement du cycle de haut
mais également de brisevent pour les
cultures mais aussi utile pour les les
troupeaux dans dans nos régions
agricooles d'élevage malgré ces
bénéfices reconnus depuis longtemps les
ha n'ont pas trouvé leur défenseur et
elles continue de disparaître lentement
de de nos paysages malgré les alertes de
certains élus face à cette situation le
gouvernement a récemment initié un Pact
en faveur de la haie et a annoncé la
mise en œuvre d'un observatoire de la
haie j'aimerais savoir comment vous
comptez atteindre l'objectif de 50000 a
nouvell d'ici 2030 les opérateurs que
j'ai entendu dans le cadre de mes
auditions budgétaires m'ont indiqué
qu'aujourd'hui personne n'est en mesure
de quantifier précisément les
plantations et les arrachage à l'échelle
nationale une comptabilité spécifique
des en flux et en stock s'avère à mon
sens nécessaire est-ce une préoccupation
que vous partagez et quel mécanisme
comptez-vous déployer en direction des
agriculteurs et des propriétaires
fonciers pour accroître l'acceptabilité
économique des j'ajoute par ailleurs que
l'impact du déploiement de la fibbr
optique aussi sur les territoires a eu
des effets souvent négatifs sur les les
air en lisière de de champ agricole la
solution de l'enfouissement étant
onéreuse mais qui aura été plus sécurisé
notamment dans le contexte de changement
climatique donc il faut vraiment
monsieur le ministre donner les moyen à
l'agriculture de préserver ses a et
aussi simplifier parce que les a c'est
régi par plus de 5 codes donc si on veut
de la de l'efficacité il faut aussi de
la
simplicité par ailleurs donc sur le
projet loi de finance l'article 16 du
projet de loi pour 2024 réforme quant à
lui les redevances perçu par les agence
de l'eau ainsi que l'avait déjà prévu
les assises de l'eau de 2019 et le plan
haut présenté en mars dernier l'idée de
rééquilibrer la charge fiscale entre les
différentes catégories d'usagers de
l'eau et accompagner le relèvement du
plafond mordant des recettes des agences
de l'eau vous en avez parlé il ça mérite
d'être salué car elle améliorera la
qualité du signal prix de la facture
d'eau et constiue une première brique
vers une sobriété accrue des usages
parilleurs la redevance pour pollution
diffuse est rehaussée et ce budget fixe
un taux minimum et un maximum pour les
autres redevances en laissant le soin au
comité de bassin de voter un taux dans
cette fourchette un prix plancher a
également été défini pour les
prélèvements d'eau pour l'irrigation
mais un coût de 0,2 centimes d'euros par
mètre Cu pour un système gravitaire et
de 1,41 centimes d'euros par mètre cube
pour les autres méthodes ce sont de
premières avancées pour résorber le
déficit de financement par les usagers
autres que les ménages mais elles sont
encore bien timides est-ce à la hauteur
d'un plan Marchal en faveur des
collectivités dont les réseaux affichent
dans certains cas des fuites à plus de
50 %. est-ce suffisant pour renforcer la
résilience hydrique de notre pays dans
un contexte de changement climatique de
même je ne trouve pas de trace de la
redevance dédiée à la biodiversité
réclamée par de nombreux acteurs pour
financer les actions des agences de
l'eau sur le grand cycle de l'eau et la
restauration de la biodiversité pourquoi
n'avoir pas donné suite à cette demande
pourtant légitime et enfin j'aurai une
dernière interrogation ou plutôt un
point de vigilance qui ressort d'un
certain nombre de mes auditions
budgétaires plusieurs opérateurs des
programmes 113 et 159 m'ont signalé les
difficultés qui résultent de la
circulaire budgétaire du 11 juin 2010
selon laquelle tous les emplois
permanents doivent être inclus dans le
plafond d'emploi des opérateurs de
l'État quel que soit leur modalité de
financement si la logique prené par
cette circulaire é loouable à savoir la
nécessaire maîtrise de l'emploi public
dans le contexte des finances publiqu
que l'on connaît et la soutenabilité du
financement des emplois des opérateurs
elle conduit cependant à des difficultés
notamment pour faire face à la
saisonnalité de certaines missions et au
développement des recettes commerciales
de certains opérateurs est-ce une
difficulté que vous avez identifié
comment surmonter le paradoxe de la
nécessité de renforcer les recettes
propres grâce à de nouvelles activités
lucratives de certains opérateurs dans
un contexte aussi de gratuité de la
donnée publique avec les contraintes
existantes en matière de schéma d'emploi
je pourrais vous donner le détail des
opérateurs qui m'ont indiqué cette
problématique je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
merci il faudra que les commissaires
raccourcissent un tout petit peu parce
que sinon j'ai encore plein de demandes
de de parole la parole est à Louisan
Deol merci monsieur le
Président mon propos sadress plus
spécifiquement Dominique for la ministre
délégué auprès des collectivités
territorial mais comme la D permet que
il vaut mieux s'adresser au bon Dieu
qu'asses je me permets je me permets
aussi en faire pas monsieur le ministre
je souhait tout d'abord vous interroger
sur l'évolution des dotations
d'investissement aux collectivité
territoriale et plus particulièrement
sur la detetr et la descil en 2024 la
DTR comme la descil resta quasi
resteront quasiment stables et pourtant
les collectivités doivent aujourd'hui
faire face à une inflation et une hausse
de taux d'intérêt sans précédent tout en
continuant à rattraper le retard
d'investissement causé par 2 années de
crise sanitaire certes dans le le cadre
de votre plan France ruralité les
dotation attribué à l'ingénierie
territoriale augmente à hauteur de 20
millions d'euros tandis que 100 postes
de chef de projet sont créés dans le
cadre du programme villageavenir pour un
coût de 6 millions d'euros vous aidez
donc les collectivités dans
l'élaboration de leur projet de leur
projet d'investissement mais sans pour
autant leur donner les moyens d'investir
et ils sont inquiets sur ces
possibilités comment comptez-vous
soutenir ou faire face à
l'investissement local sans augmenter
les dotations de soutien à
l'investissement des collectivités
territ face à l'inflation des coûts et
des taux
d'intérêt ma deuxème question porte sur
la la NCT durant l'examen de la
proposition de loi créant la NCT pour
lequel j'étais rapporteur au nom de
cette commission nous avions émis le
souhait de recréer une DATAR une agence
unique de l'aménagement du territoire
nous avions cependant accepté la
survivance de certaines agences au côté
de la NCT tout en instaurant des
conventions de coordination pour assurer
une action publique cohérente les
premières conventions de coordination
avec le serema la caisse Dépôts et
Consignation Lana l'anrue et laadème
sont aujourd'hui arrivés à leur terme et
une nouvelle génération de conventions
est en cours de signature ne serait-ce
pas le moment d'engager une réflexion
sur le périmètre de la NCT pour
rationnaliser ce qu'on pourrait appeler
un archipel et territoire enfin
j'aimerais vous interroger sur les
contrats de relance et de transition
écologique crte devenu contrat de
réussite de la transition écologique
j'ai constaté sur le terrain que le crte
n'a pas rempli sa promesse d'un contrat
intégrateur et finit par simplement
ajouter une couche au millefeuillees de
des documents d'aménagement du
territoire bien souvent le crte qui est
conçu au niveau intercommunal n'est pas
l'expression d'un projet de territoire
mais une simple liste de projets locaux
la Cour des comptes dans un rapport paru
en octobre 2023 dresse le même constat
observant que les crte se chevauchent
avec d'autres contrats et ne jouent pas
le rôle d'agrégateur espéré la 2è
génération de crte annoncé prend-elle en
compte ses critiques comment
comptez-vous y remédier pour faire en
sorte que le crte ne soit pas un
document d'aménagement supplémentaire
mais bien un contrat intégrateur porté
porteur d'un projet de
territoire j'ai don la parole à réi poou
puis après je propose au ministre de
répondre et j'aurai encore un certain
nombre de intervention des commissaires
puis après les
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je souhaiterit tout d'abord
évoquer le sujet des zones de
revitalisation rurale ou comme vous
proposez de est nommé les zones France
ruralité revitalisation et en effet ces
exonérations fiscales auxquels les élus
sont sont très attachés doivent être
réformés et on en convient tous la
réforme que vous proposz dans le cadre
de ce projet de loi de finance na
cependant rien à voir même va à
l'inverse des préconisations du rapport
d'information adopté adopté par notre
commission en janvier 2023 nous avions
identifié deux problèmes tout d'abord la
maille intercommunale insuffisamment
fine et les critères retenus qui ne
permettent pas d'apprécier la diversité
des situations des communes rurales pour
un zonage qui soit plus juste et et
mieux ciblé et je regrette que ce projet
de loi finance ne règle aucun de ces
deux problèmes puisqu'il conserve la
maille intercommunale et les critères de
classement actuels pour mon département
c'est 92 communes qui sortent dont les
communes les plus fragiles du
département et avec dans un département
qui perd des habitants et en même temps
vous introduisez un troisième problème
c'est-à-dire l'intégration d'air
urbaines dans un un zonage rural puisque
vous proposez en effet de classer
intégralement six départements ce qui
amène à faire bénéficiers des villes de
plus de 25000 habitants d'exonérations
qui sont conçu spé spcifiquement pour
les espaces
ruraux le classement en zone France
ruralité revitalisation d' urbaine
danssément peuplé ne risquet-il pas de
nuire au vrais territoires rau en besoin
de revitalisation et pourquoi conserver
le maillage intercommunal alors que le
Sénat tout comme l'Association des
maires de France l'association des
maires ruraux de France d'ailleurs
préconise un classement à la maille
communale d'autre part ayant sur un
autre sujet ayant mené une
mission avec mon collègue Hervé gilet
mission d'information sur la gestion
durable de l'eau on s'intéresse
également à la mise en œuvre du plan eau
et à son déploiement territorial et le
projet de loi de finance porte diverses
mesures pour assurer son financement
comme le le relèvement du plafond
mordant des recettes des agences de
l'eau ou la réforme des redevances en
visant notamment un soutient renforcé
aux 170 collectivités dont les réseaux
d'eau potable ont un rendement inférieur
à 50 % ou encore la création d'un fond
hydraulique agricole pour accompagner
les agriculteurs face à la nouvelle
donne climatique et hydrique quel bilan
tirez-vous de du déploiement des mesures
du plan haut comment évolue le travail
d'interconnexion des réseau des communes
identifiées comme étant fragiles parce
qu'ayant dû faire face à des ruptures
d'approvision iement au cours des deux
derniers étés et comment évoluent les
discussions dans les bassins sur le
volet sobriété des usag et réduction des
prélèvements et sur enfin sur la
réutilisation des EAU usées traité vous
misez sur un millier de projets pour des
usage non domestique quelles sont les
dynamiques amorcées sur ces questions au
cours des 6 premiers mois du déploiement
plan
haut monsieur le ministre alors
je vais être rapide pour aller droit au
but sur les sur les différentes réponses
quit à prendre un chouill à plus de
temps sur une ou deux mais pour aller
vite
ICPE nous prévoyons 100 postes au budget
2024 et c'est une base après trois fois
plus 25 au cours de ces dernières années
pour être capable d'intensifier et de
tenir le rythme de contrôle là où vous
avez raison c'est que c'est pas parce
que les postes sont ouverts qu'on a
forcément des candidats augmentation des
salaires euh rendre les carrières plus
attractives concours exceptionnel pour
rajouter des dates ce sont autant de
leviers sur lequel nous misons je peux
vous assurer que depuis que je suis en
responsabilité depuis un peu plus de 500
jours mon obsession c'est bien que les
engagements qui ont été pris par le
passé soit tenu ce qui explique l'effort
budgétaire exceptionnel que nous allons
faire au titre de l'année qui arrive
parce que nous partageons l'idée qu'on a
besoin dans ce domaine de faire preuve
de confiance et vous avez cité industrie
verte notre intérêt écologique est
d'arrêter d'importer massivement du bout
du monde un certain nombre de choses
c'est notre intérêt économique mais
c'est également notre intérêt écologique
mais on sait que ça pourra se heurter à
des difficultés d'acceptation de la part
des populations locales qui
nécessiteront d'être d'autant plus
capable de faire les contrôles qui
permettent de rassurer les gens sur la
transparence que nous leur devons
amaris je ne peux pas remettre en cause
le bilan chiffré j'ai un léger désaccord
sur le constat à lire le rapport amaris
on a le sentiment que sur les PPRT les
plans de prévention des risques
technologiques le seul souci serait du
côté de l'État je vous rappelle qu'on
est sur un système à double cliquet vous
avez l'État qui subventionne à hauteur
de 40 % qui prescrit des mesures qui
subventionne et les expros qui sont
gérés par les collectivités local la
situation est contrastée pour le dire
avec le mot qui convient elle est
contrastée parce que 83 % des
expropriations de maisons ou de logement
ont eu lieu mais seulement 50 % au titre
des activités économiques et quand je
superpose ces chiffres sur la nature des
activités à la carte des territoires on
s'aperçoit donc certains endroits on est
proche de 100 dans d'autres on est loin
du compte et on est plus proche de zéro
donc c'est moins une question de volonté
politique qu'une question de suivi
territoriale puisqueencore une fois dans
un certain nbre de territoire ça n'est
pas le manque de moyens qu'on nous
oppose c'est un manque de volontarisme
pour tenir compte de ce qui se fait mais
on va évidemment donner une suite à ce
rapport enfin sur les
inondations
un 20 millions d'euros de rajout au fond
Barnier effectivement dans le contexte
dans lequel nous sommes de un constat
qui n'est pas une promesse il se trouve
que nous avons eu à hauteur de 40
millions d'euros des subventions fonds
verts qu'on a attribué sur des
programmes qui servent à lutter contre
les inondation on l'avait pas projeté il
y a un an mais on avait rendu possible
que des collectivités puissent demander
des margés au titre de ces crédits il
est pas exclu qu'on ait l'année
prochaine plus de demandes 3 on va avoir
besoin d'un retour d'expérience un tout
petit peu plus fouillé que le constat de
désolation qu'on a en ce moment dans le
Pas de Calet en vrai nos dispositifs de
prévention ont plutôt marché quand vous
pensez qu'on est sur le niveau
historique pour la a pour la
Canche pour la M ou pour la Lian avec
des endroits où on dépasse de 50 cm à 1
m les plus hautes eau jamais mesuré et
qu'on a moins de sinistrés qu'on en
avait en 2002 on se dit qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose entre les deux le
entre les deux c'est des PPRI qui sont
parfois décriés quand il y a pas
d'inondation mais dont on a pu voir une
partie de l'efficacité c'est des
dispositifs de dig qui ont nécessité des
investissements de la part des
collectivités territoriales
importante qui ont permis de limiter les
dégâts et pour avoir échangé avec
Martial Sadier sur un tout autre
territoire après des inondations record
dans la vallée de l'Arve où on a des
niveaux historiques qui dépassent les
records de cru de ces dernières années
les travaux qui ont été conduits
notamment avec laange de l'eau ont
permis là aussi de ne pas avoir des
niveaux historiques de dégâts là où par
le passé des crus moins élevés en avait
amené le retour d'expérience ce sera sur
la prévention sans attendre il faut
qu'on simplifie les règles de curage et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
répondu tout à l'heure à l'occasion des
questions au gouvernement que là-dessus
il fallait qu'on simplifie les choses et
ça va me permettre de faire le lien avec
la ha si vous voulez bien les autres
mesures de suivi
euh en particulier il y en a plein il y
en a qui relèvent des catastrophes
naturelles est-ce qu'il faut qu'on
continue à demander à des mères
d'exprimer eux-mêmes une demande de
catastrophe naturelle quand ils peuvent
plus accéder à leur mairie est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas autoriser quand on a des
mairies qui sont inondés que ce soit le
préfet qui fasse la demande pour le
compte des communes est-ce que en
matière de pprri les durées d'études
sont raisonnables est-ce que dans un
certain nombre de cas ù vu du terrain on
sait ce que sont des travaux de
conortement qui sont à conduire on doit
pas inverser une forme de logique de
confiance plutôt que de rester sur des
principes de précaution qui sont trop
absolus et donc nous aurons ces retours
et puis on a des questions de pompage on
voit leur efficacité à l'heure actuelle
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on laisse des
pompes dans des territoires sur lesquels
on sait qu'on a ce type de risque qu'on
les confie éventuellement à VNF et enfin
comment font nos voisins parce que notre
humilité française habituelle ne doit
pas nous ne doit pas n nous conduire à
ne pas regarder ce que d'autres font
dans des territoires comparables avec
d'autres histoires et peut-être parfois
avec des résultats que nous avons
intérêt à regarder la e 70 % c'est le
recul du linéaire de depuis 1950 et donc
je veux dire au sénateur chevrolier dont
je sais la sincérité de l'engagement sur
ces sujets et sur ces combats y compris
contenu du bocage mayenis dont il est le
fervant défenseur que si nous avons
initié un plan S et à la fois parce que
nous avons on se constate d'un point de
vue numérique mais que quand on regarde
on s'aperçoit de la multiplicité des
causes qui ont conduit à ce
recul il y a des causes que je
qualifierait de budgetaire c'est pas les
plus nombreuses mais les 110 millions
d'euros par an que le masa va mettre
jusqu'à la fin de ce quinena sur le plan
a vont être un moyen d'accompagner les
porteurs de projets l'Observatoire pour
qu'on objective les éléments on a des
sujets qui peuvent concerner les
collectivités territoriales pour être
capable que quand elle subventionnent
des a elles puisse les faire figurer
dans des document d'urbanisme et et donc
leur confier une possibilité pour agir
mais on a aussi parfois une inqu étude
d'agriculteurs qui disent que s'il
plantent une e et que pour une raison
quelconque ils sont obligés de la
détruire si à l'intérieur il y a des
espèces protégées ils sont susceptibles
de tomber sous le coup de sanction
pénale et donc que c'est la peur d'une
forme de principe de précaution de
préservation de la biodiversité qui les
conduit à ne pas agir très concrètement
si on ne joue pas sur ces différents
leviers en trouvant les bons points
d'arbitrage on n arrivera pas le plan et
doit être présenté pour la toute fin de
l'année il est coporté à la fois par
Marc fenau et par Sarah Ely mais qui est
ma secrétaire d'État délégué donc je le
suis évidemment ce qui me conduit à
pouvoir vous apporter ces premiers
éléments de réponse même si je pourrais
pas être aussi précis que l'un ou
l'autre pourrait l'être vous
m'interroger ensuite sur la redevance de
l'eau sur la réforme et sur les
perspectives première innovation que
j'assume le fait que nous
ayons non je vais pas vous répondre de
cette manière pour que le plan soit
crédible il faut des
moyens nous savons comment est-ce qu'on
a calibré les moyens de ce plan haut à
la satisfaction de tous les comités de
bassin sans exception qui ont salué le
montant en nous apercevant que
globalement avec environ 2 milliards
d'euros dans les agences il y a 20
milliards d'euros de travaux quand on
mesure ce qu'il faut qu'on investisse
dans le pays on se rend compte que la
moyenne devrait être à 25 comp tenu des
fuites comp tenu de la résilience cont
tenu de la rehute et donc nous
augmentons de 25 % les moyens des
agences en considérant que ça aura
l'effet de levier parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que dans ce cas-là l'eau paye
l'eau sur les territoires et que dans
beaucoup de cas y compris avec des
aquaprès d'une durée de 40 ou de 50 ans
on amortit les travaux qu'on fait à
l'échelle d'une
collectivité en revanche qui paye l'eau
les particuliers et les agriculteurs qui
ne paye pas les énergéticiens alors
qu'il prélève une partie importante la
nouveauté dans la redevance c'est que
nous allons fixer un plancher à 100
millions d'euros de contribution à
l'intérieur des sommes dont nous parlons
qui permettent d'éviter qu'on fasse
porter sur les seuls particuliers et sur
les ailes de l'agriculteur une partie du
coût global et qu'on fasse là aussi la
vérité des coûts y compris sur la
production de origine nucléaire dont
nous connaissons l'impact et
l'importance pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone mais qui doit
contribuer à sa part pour éviter que ne
s'ouvre une forme de biais sur la
contestation de ces vertus quand on fait
ça ensuite ça permet évidemment de
soulager le reste de l'augmentation de
la redevance on modifie de trois
critères on fixe des planchers parce
qu'il peut y avoir des hétérogénéités
que vous avez rappelé sur lesquelles je
reviens pas un bout de redevance pour
pollution diffuse parce qu'on se
concentre sur la question de la quantité
mais la question de la qualité doit nous
interpeller 44 % seulement des masse
d'eau dans ce pays en bon état
écologique et un principe simple c'est
que puisque le volume d'eau prélevable
va diminuer la quantité potentielle des
intrants dans les PL de captage va être
renforcé puisqu'on diminuera le volume
d'eau à l'intérieur desquels ces
concentrations se retrouvent et donc
avec des risques de fermeture sanitaire
qui nécessite d'intensifier des mesures
agroécologiques et des pgse à l'échelle
de ces captages d'où l'augmentation de
la redevance de pollution diffuse en
revanche dans l'équation vous citez un
chiffre qui est est repris également par
le président pointero sur
l'accompagnement des fuites 170 communes
ce sont les seules communes à plus de 50
% qui se sont déclaré pour l'année
2023 et pour lesqueles nous déployons
180 millions d'euros là le nombre de
communes qui est à plus de 50 % est sans
doute plus élevé mais un certain ne se
signale pas de crainte qu'on les oblige
à s'intercommunaliser plus vite j'aurai
l'occasion de redire un mot très rapide
là-dessus il ne peut pas y avoir un
système dans lequel des territoires où
on n'a pas assumé des hausses du prix de
l'eau pour être capable de financer des
les travaux seraiit intégralement
subventionnés par l'État alors que en
quelque sorte ils ont joué au passagers
clandestin là où des territoires qui ont
assumé leurs responsabilités et qui ont
assumé des hausses de quelques centimes
pour aller faire ses travaux aujourd'hui
ont des niveaux de résilience qui sont
bien plus élevés donc il y a une part de
ce financement qui doit relever des
collectivités il y a un aspect qui
manque et qui touche à un autre sujet
qui est la question de
l'artificialisation nous avons eu mes
chers collègues des débats sur le fait
qu'à un moment pour que le dispositif
boucle il manque manqu potentiellement
un volet fiscal ou une capacité à faire
en sorte de désinciter à artificialiser
d'un point de vue fiscal pour générer
des ressources dans ce pays environ 6500
communes ont décidé d'activer un
dispositif que toutes ne connaissent pas
et qui permet d'aller taxer les
plusvalus de cession des terrains rendus
artificiels dès lors que ces sessions
dépassent un X 3 en terme de revente
avec des conditions détenenstion et
cetera je pousse l'idée que nous devons
dans ce domaine faire en sorte de
générer une recette au titre de
l'artificialisation qui alimente
notamment le budget des agences de l'eau
pour moitié et le budget des communes
pour l'autre les agences de l'eau parce
que ça correspond globalement à la
préservation de la biodive puisque
l'artificialisation a comme première
conséquence cette érosion de la
biodiversité bouche les napes fréatique
et conduit ensuite à des écoulements
plus rapides mais à l'inverse pour aider
également les communes pour avoir des
recettes qui leur permettent de pouvoir
investir sur les dépollutions des
friches cet amendement est soutenu par
toutes les agences quel que soi leur
couleur politique il a reçu le soutien
tien de la MF il est vu d'un œil positif
par les agriculteurs parce qu'il
générait 12 millions de plus pour les
jeunes agriculteurs en conduisant un
doublement du rendement et je ne doute
pas que un sénateur dans les prochaines
heures déposera cet amendement qui fait
l'objet d'un regard bienveillant à ce
stade du ministre mais qui est examiné
en haut lieu avec insistance également
euh et et dont le le rendement global
est assez faible parce qu'on parle
d'environ 200 millions d'euros et que ça
n'est pas une augmentation de
prélèvement obligatoire puisque ce que
nous ne faisons pas dans taxe on fera
par la redevance donc à la fin c'est
étal sur le plan des dépenses publiques
le sujet c'est est-ce qu'on Toxe est-ce
que on va vers une recette qui est liée
au stock ou une recette qui est liée au
flux je suis à votre disposition enfin
la circulaire du en juin
2010 je vous découvre des talents de
d'archéologue parce que cette circulaire
du 1 juin 2010 je vous avoue que je ne
la connaissais pas spontanément avant
que la question me soit posée et vous
avez eu l'amabilité de transmettre à mon
cabinet le fait qu'il y aurait une
question sur ce sujet sinon j'aurais été
obligé de sécher sur ce point la
différence des autres c'est un fa
problème la preuve c'est que ces
plafonds d'emploi déterminés à l'époque
sous d'autres gouvernements n'ont pas
été spécialement remis en cause parce
qu'il permettait d'éviter qu'on se
retrouve avec des inflations de
personnel qui ne soient pas vu depuis le
central au moment où nous recréons des
postes ça va atténuer une partie de ces
difficultés et le meilleur exemple ce
sont les agences de l'eau pour
lesquelles j'envisage 66 création de
postes l'année prochaine en modifiant
les plafonds d'emploi qui sont imaginés
pourquoi est-ce que la circulaire a été
faite pour éviter que au moment où on a
une disponibilité budgétaire temporaire
on fasse des contrats et qu'ensuite on
explique qu'on est amené à faire des
plans de licenciement puisqu'on a
utilisé la Tréo pour payer des dépenses
courantes et récurrentes donc il y a une
forme de morale budgétaire à ce qu'on
puisse conserver des plafonds même si
parfois il faudrait être capable de les
assouplir notamment ce qui concerne le
recours au contractuel mais à ce stade
les créations pour l'année qui arrive
vont permettre de régler une partie des
soucis et j'attends avec impatience la
liste de ceux qui vous ont sollicité sur
le sujet louis- Jean ncolaï je réponds
avec joie en lieu et place de Dominique
fort le niveau du concours aux
collectivités territorial atteint le
record l'année prochaine de
7,1 7,1 milliard d'euros
d'investissement c'est juste sans
équivalent puisque c'est même supérieur
au crédit qu'il y avait pendant le plan
de relance c'est lié à quoi c'est lié à
la progression du fond vert à hauteur
d'un demi mililliard d'euros et c'est
lié au fait que la DETR et la décil ne
bouge pas mais vous auriez pu dire
qu'elle ne bouge pas et qu'elle reste à
leors plus haut niveau historique qui
est hérité du plan de relance et qui
conservé ces enveloppes de crédit on
pourra toujours considérer qu'elles ne
sont pas suffisantes je note juste
qu'elles sont historique et qu'elle
marque une progression de près de 10 %
quand on compare d'une année sur l'autre
la réalité des crédits vous m'interrogez
sur la
NCT j'ai lu un excellent rapport du
Sénat il y a quelques
mois qui s'interrogeait sur le risque
d'agenciarisation de l'État et ce mot
que je ne connaissais pas a évidemment
retenu mon
attention je suis pas du tout convaincu
que la solution à la multiplication des
agences soit la création d'une nouvelle
agence je pense en
revanche que là où la création d'agence
a permis d'apporter de la souplesse il
faut qu'on recrée des portes d'entrée
uniques et que sur le modèle de ce que
vous avez fait dans cet hémicycle
pendant la loi 3DS en faisant du préfet
le référent départemental de l'ADEM pour
être certain qu'on n pas obligé d'aller
discuter alors même que ce sont des
fonds qui sont voté par le Parlement
auprès de plusieurs on pourrait imaginer
que les portes d'entrée de d'autres
agences y compris celles que que vous
avez cité soit davantage au titre de la
préfecture ce qui permettrait déjà de
recréer de la souplesse et que l'offre
d'ingénierie à disposition des maires
soit immédiatement visible à partir
d'une entrée qui existe et pas à partir
d'une structure dont il faudrait qu'on
vote les statuts qu'on décide de la
gouvernance qu'on cré des budgets qu'on
fasse en sorte de délimiter la place
qu'elle a par rapport à celle qui
existe et puis à propos de rapports
sénatoriaux vous m'interrogez sur les
crte et là je vous renvoie au rapport du
9 novembre de Monsieur Martin monsieur
benaroche et Monsieur Burgoa qui pointe
il me semble que c'est dans sa
recommandation numéro 5 la suggestion
que les crte soient financièrement doté
pour ne pas juste rester des revues de
projet mais puisse devenir l'outil je
cite toujours de la réussite de la
transition
écologique vous m'avez interrogé et
cette journée est marquée d'une pierre
blanche dans mon agenda pour que je
puisse venir mardi faire un débat avec
vous sur la planification écologique au
Sénat à l'heure des QAG de l'Assemblée
je vous remercie de me dispenser de
cette autre oation législative pendant
le Salon des Maires je m'y rendrai avec
joie et je pense qu'on aura l'occasion
de reparler de cte et de la place que
j'envisage de leur donner dans le cadre
de la planification parce que si on n
pas capable de mettre des tuyaux de
financement qui arrivent en face des
tuyaux de projets on alimentera
effectivement une forme de suspition sur
la capacité des territoires de pouvoir
avancer le président poter a donc me
décidé de me parler des
Zr vaste
sujet les sont censé s'arrêter au 31
décembre de cette année il était donc de
toute façon nécessaire qu'on imagine un
dispositif ce dispositif conçu dans le
cadre de plan de France ruralité a fait
l'objet de discussion avec vous et je
vous le dis d'emblé j'ai bien conscience
que le dispositif actuel est sans doute
améliorable d'ici la fin du travail sur
le
PLF plusieurs sujets que vous avez
pointé la maille vous avez eu l'élégance
de ne pas évoquer le nombre de
bénéficiaires pourtant je pense qu'il
est présent dans l'esprit et quand vous
citez le chiffre des 92 dans votre
commune chaque peut être capable de
faire ce calcul chez lui et puis enfin
le statut potentiel des villes centre à
partir du moment où on serait dans des
dispositifs de classement qui seraient
très
englobant la maille la vérité m'oblige à
reconnaître que la maille a toujours été
intercommunale depuis la création des Zr
en
1995 et qu'à ce stade c'est peut-être la
limite d'être le porte-parole de
Dominique fort sur le sujet mais c'est
en tout cas ce qui m'avait semblé ce que
je peux vous dire et la chose suivante
la nouveauté c'est que ça n'est pas tout
à fait une maille intercommunale c'est
une maille intercommunale avec une
possibilité de rattrapage à l'échelle
communale qui pourrait concerner dans
les premières épures que nous avons plus
de 3000 communes c'est donc tout sauf
anecdotique la maille intercommunale a
été choisie au titre de la continuité
des dispositifs existants elle pose la
difficulté de se retrouver avec des
communes très rurales don des
intercommunalités dont la taille moyenne
a augmenté il est donc nécessaire
d'imaginer un dispositif de rattrapage
le vrai souci à mon sens il est plutôt
que les critères actuels conduiraient à
exclure 3000 communes en net peut-être
même un peu plus plus près de 4
du dispositif de Zr je ne vois pas
comment nous pouvons faire un plan
France ruralité et passer de 17000 à
13000 bénéficiaires quand on connaît les
besoins et il y aura besoin d'une
évolution législative entre maintenant
et la fin du débat
parlementaire ensuite il y a la question
des communes centres et là ça renvoie au
fait de savoir s'il est souhaitable de
classer des départements entiers comme
les six qui ont été fléchés voire comme
les trois qui pourraient s'ajouter et je
ne parle ni de la Creuse ni de la niè
qui dispose de plans départementaux
particuliers c'est un vrai sujet ma
tendance personnelle c'est que si vous
mettez les mêmes avantages dans une
ville C de 15000 habitants que dans des
communes de 1500 à la fin vous dervez la
commune de 1500 et le risque que vous
prenez c'est que le médecin qui se
posera la question de savoir où il
s'installe il aura une tendance que
disje le médecin le
dentiste il aura sans doute une une
tendance à faire en sorte de se tourner
davantage vers le territoire le plus
peuplé la patientelle la plus large sera
importante donc je pense qu'on a
quelques mécanismes de correction pour
lequel la coconstruc prend tout son sens
et je peux vous assurer que la ministre
chargé des collectivités territoriales
et de la ruralité est convaincu que nous
devons bouger nous sommes en
pleine réflexion approfondie sur le
sujet je n'irai pas plus loin le Congrès
des Maires approche des annonces ou des
précisions pourrait approcher
aussi enfin vous m'interrogez sur la
question du déploiement territorial du
plan haut je reviens pas sur les
plafonds mordants ils sont cruciaux
qu'on puisse les relever au moment où
nous avons aujourd'hui les trésoreries
dormantes et l'interdiction de dépenser
une partie de ces sommes alors qu'il y a
des besoins pose évidemment une
difficulté et là aussi c'était salué et
attendu je vous redis que sur
l'accompagnement des communes
l'enveloppe de la première année ne dit
pas ce qu'elle sera pour les années qui
viennent nous avons dimensionné des
fonds pour l'hydraulique agricole nous
avons dimensionné des des crédits pour
lutter contre les fuites il y aura
maintenant à ajuster ça au niveau des
différentes agences les premières
agences les premiers comités de bassin
ont commencé à rendre leur copies en
matière de sobriété sur l'atte des 10 %
j'ai reçu un ou deux plans à ce stade et
les autres sont en pleine discussion et
un certain vont suivre dans les semaines
qui viennent ça pourrait faire l'objet
d'une communication plus spécifique sur
la réutilisation des eaux usées je
précise que demain je consacrerai toute
la matinée au plan de sobriété haut au
ministère dans un contexte où les images
du Nord de la France peuvent donner le
sentiment qu'on parle de réalités qui
sont différentes il n'empêche que quand
vous écoutez les experts on aura des
pluies plus abondantes l'hiver et des
sécheresses plus nombreuses l'été donc
ça ne modifie en rien le fait de se
poser la question de la façon dont on
régule mieux nos réserves dans un
contexte où des pluies très abondantes
ne nous ne remplissent pas aussi bien
les nappes que des pluies plus faibles
et
continue j'ajoute que sur la réute
l'objectif fixé par le plan haut à
Savine leelc était de 1000 projets d'ici
la fin du quinquena nous avons dépassé
les 500 demandes de projets de
réutilisation dès maintenant le 29 août
le décret concernant les collectivité
territoriale est sortie voirie espace
vert le décret concernant
l'agroalimentaire est au Conseil d'État
avec un impact très important sur la
capacité à pouvoir l'utiliser dans de
très nombreux domaines industriels ou
agricooles et la ministre de la Santé
aura l'occasion demain de dire un mot
délégué chargé de la santé de la partie
domestique au grise et de la capacité de
main à rendre possible qu'un lavelinge
puisse alimenter des toilettes pour
qu'on ait là aussi des types d'économie
qui peuvent s'imaginer au moment des
constructions initiales de résidence
j'ai essayé d'être aussi rapide que
possible merci je vais donner la parole
à Hervé gilet puis après à philippe
Tabarot puis après à Martha de Sidrac
puis je vais peut-être céder la la
présidence à Didier Mandelli puisque je
vais m'en aller à la Conférence des
Présidents et on va certainement aussi
parler un peu ZRR la Conférence des
Présidents monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président je
vais essayer de de faire au plus court
aussi hein je suis rapporteur donc
concernant les crédits relatifs au
transport routiers monsieur le ministre
je voudrais revenir sur leasing social
euh et donc ce leasing la mise en œuvre
a quand même pris du retard
reconnaissez-le par rapport aux annonces
initiales vous nous indiquez qu'elle est
programmée donc pour le 1er janvier 2024
on on s'en réjouit bien évidemment mais
on a toujours nous à notre niveau un
manque de visibilité sur les paramètres
précis du dispositif sachant que les
dépôts des demandes de ménage auraient
commencé ce mois-ci euh outre le niveau
de revenu quels critères d'éligibilité
seront pris en compte est-il par exemple
prévu d'introduire un critèreé
ographique lié aux zfeux et j'ai
introduit aussi faudrait-il moduler
principalement les crédits sur les 5
zdfeux prioritaires ce qui est aussi une
question qui qui est posée aujourd'hui
s'agissant du calibrage financier un
plafond de 100 € de loyer par mois hors
assurance est donc prévu combien de
modèles de véhicules seraient donc
compatibl avec ces critères et l'offre
de véhicules éliggible au leasing
sera-t-elle suffisante pour répondre à
la demande selon vous une enveloppe de
50 millions d'euros est prévu pour
financer ce dispositif en 2024 sur C
base avez-vous estimé le nombre de
bénéficiaires potentiel vous nous avez
parlé de 20 à 25000 c'est bien ça si
j'ai bien compris pour la première année
prévoyez-vous donc une montée en charge
du dispositif pour les années suivantes
donc on a besoin d'une clarification je
précise qu'il y avait une rencontre
ministérielle qui était prévue avec les
chefs de fil de collectivité en
septembre et qui n'a pas eu lieu donc
les attentes sont très fortes et les
auditions le font remarquer deuxièmement
je souhaite aborder le dispositif de
lecture automatisé des plaques
d'immatriculation d'il laapis dont la
mise en œuvre en zdfeu autorisée par la
h n'a eu de cesse d'être reporté depuis
4 ans rappelons que d'ici à peine plus
d'un an ce sont 43 agglomérations qui
devront avoir mis en place Desf en
application de la loi climat et
résionance puisquon est toujours sur ce
calendrier on est bien d'accord or
comment assurer la crédibilité du
dispositif si ces collectivités ne sont
pas doté de moyens adéquates pour
contrôler le respect des restrictions de
de circulation qu'elles devront mettre
en place pouvons-nous les exposer les
raisons du retard technique juridique
nous indiquer où en sont les travaux du
Gouvernement sur ce sujet la la sera
t-elle bien disponible en 2024 et puis
les modalités d'acquisition de cet outil
sucit des inquiétudes légitimes au sein
des agglomérations qui sont donc
concernés par ces a des feu avez-vous
estimé le coût d'acquisition de cet
outils un soutien financier de l'État
est-il prévu sur ce point pour terminer
je souhaite aborder l'enjeu de
l'interopérabilité des bandes de
recharge électrique un sujet qui gagne
en importance comp tenu du déploiement
progressif et notamment des des afeu
quelles mesures allez-vous mettre en
œuvre pour favoriser l'interopérabilité
des bandes de charge des différents
opérateurs ça fonctionne mais c'est
quand même pas aujourd'hui d'une
efficience considérable et donc c'est un
sujet particulièrement important je vous
remercie merci HERV la parole est à
Philippe tabarou
ouis monsieur le Président Mandelli
monsieur le ministre
euh je vais faire ENF cela vous
surprendra pas mais je vais faire un
petit pas de côté également par rapport
au PLF et et je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur le déploiement des ZFE si
en complément et si mon collègue gilet
bien sûr le le permet
euh en effet le Ministre délégué bonne a
répondu à mes questions sur le programme
203 sur les infrastructures et services
de de transport euh comme vous le savez
notre commission adopté en en juin
dernier un autre excellent rapport
d'information intitulé zdfe sortir de
l'impasse au terme d'une mission flash
la mission part d'un constat simple
partout où elles sont instituées les DFE
se heurent à d'important crispation et à
de vives incompréhension à la fois de la
part des collectivités à qui il
reviennent de les mettre en place et des
usagers particulier comme professionnels
qui verront pour une part importante
d'entre eux leurs véhicules affectés par
les restrictions de circulation dans les
agglomérations connaissant des
dépassements réguliers des seuils de
qualité je les rappelle c'est vous qui
les avez donnés Paris Lyon Marseille
Strasbourg et
rouand chers collègue Martin je sais que
vous monsieur le ministre vous comptez
tester quelque part ces ces chiffres
pourtant ils ne sont que le reflet de la
composition du parc automobile français
à l'heure actuelle 13 millions de
véhicules particuliers sont classés
critère 5 à 3 ou non classés de fait
c'est 34 % du parc national de véhicules
qui ne pourra pas accéder aux
agglomérations auxquelles s'applique le
schéma de restriction voté par la loi
climat et résilience que je viens de
citer certes et fort heureusement ces 13
millions de véhicules ne sont pas tous
répartis dans dans les seules unités
urbaines des quelques ZFE qui se verront
appliquer ce chemin pour autant ces
véhicules ne pourront y pénétrer sauf à
revoir le calendrier de déploiement
comme nous l'avons proposé je souligne
d'ailleurs qu'il ne s'agit pas de
reporter pour reportter mais d'être
pragmatique ce calendrier n'est pas et
ne pourra pas être respecté l'effort de
communication que vous avez conduit avec
le talent qui vous caractérise monsieur
le ministre en juillet dernier à per
permis de clarifier la situation et de
li citer publiquement enfin les AFE
concernés par les schémas de restriction
de circulation pour autant ce calendrier
de mise en œuvre n'a pas été modifié
depuis lors vos prédécesseurs votre
prédécesseur madame pompil a également
conduit une mission sur l'acceptabilité
des zones à faible émission en partant
de l'expérience de nos voisins européens
son rapport propose également un certain
nombre de recommandations nous avons
appris par la presse que vous deviez
formuler des annonces sur les ZF fe
mi-novembre et coïncidence du calendrier
nous sommes le 15 novembre voilà ça
tombe bien donc quelles sont les
évolutions envisagées à ce jour
entendez-vous vous inspirer des travaux
du Sénat sur ce sujet notamment de la
proposition de loi que nous avons déposé
en juillet dernier qui porte sur le
renforcement de l'information et de la
concertation de l'assouplissement du
calendrier ou encore sur une
intensification des aides à l'atention
des publics concernés et cela m'amène un
tout dernier point où en Éton de la mise
en œuvre du prêt à taux zéro pour les
personnes travaillant ou résident ZFE
comme vous le savez il s'agit d'un
dispositif qui a été introduit à
l'initiative du Sénat nous nous
inquiétons de son
retard merci Philippe avant de laisser
la parole à Martha Sidrac dans la mesure
où le ministre doit nous quitter dans
quelques dizaines de minutes dans une 25
à 30 minutes je vais vous donner les
règles de fonctionnement pour la suite
euh il y a un certain nombre de prise de
parole je ne pourrais pas satisfaire
tout le monde donc je vais demander je
donnerai priorité à ceux au groupes qui
ne sont pas représentés dans les
rapports donc je demande
à donc à Chac et il a deux prises de
parole pour geste donc je vous demande
de vous mettre d'accord pour qu'un seul
intervienne euh et puis Jean yvrou
pourra
intervenir ainsi que marieclaude varayas
pour les autres je suis désolé si on a
le temps je vous laisserai la parole
mais je donnerai priorité si vous
l'acceptez à ceux que je viens de citer
Martha merci président monsieur le
ministre merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui vous avez cité un certain
nombre de rapports sénatoriaux que vous
avez qualifié d'excellent je vous
espérez que vous avez lu le mien celui
de juillet concernant bien évidemment la
réduction le réemploi de tout enfin tout
ce qui le recyclage des emballages donc
je vais vous interroger là-dessus il
traduit très clairement ma position sur
la consigne sujet éminemment important
et éminemment j'ai envie de dire
irritant parfois pour nos collectivités
mais surtout il a fait 28 propositions
très clair pour nous permettre en
réalité de pouvoir améliorer nos
performances en matière d'économie
circulaire moi je serai très Brè et très
directe certaines de ces propositions
certaines de ces mesures mériteraient
d'être traduit en amendement dans le
casadre du PLF ce que j'envisage de
faire et donc j'aurais souhaité avoir
votre position et savoir Monsieur le
Ministre si je pourrait compter sur
votre soutien s'agissant d'un certain
nombre de ces mesures je pense plus
particulièrement à euh la tarification
initatif par exemple je fais un certain
nombre de propositions dans le cadre de
ce rapport et si vous permettez une
deuxième question concernant la consigne
elle-même puisque à l'occasion des
Assises de Nantes en septembre tout le
monde a cru comprendre et j'ose espérer
que nous avions tous très bien compris
que la consigne pour les bouteilles en
plastique pour le recyclage des
bouteilles en plastique a priori n'était
plus à l'ordre du jour or lorsqu'on
observe aujourd'hui en réalité la
consultation les agréments et le nouveau
cahier de charge des
éco-organismes un certain nombre de
doutes s'est imissé dans l'esprit de nos
collectivités un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes et j'aurais souhaiter
véritablement monsieur le ministre que
vous nous rassuriez à l'occasion
d'aujourd'hui voilà je vous remercie
merci Mara avant de laisser la par le
ministre je précise quand même que
j'avais prévu de poser une question et
que je m'en suis exclu évidemment je dis
pour les collègues il y av TR ou quatre
collègues LR donc je leur dis pour je le
dis pour eux aussi monsieur ministre je
vais répondre aussi vite que je peux
même si certaines de ces questions sont
un tout petit peu plus
techniques sur le leasing sur le leasing
je moi dans ce que je sais c'est que
l'année dernière au salon deautomobile
le président de la République a dit que
le dispositif de réservation ouvrirait
avant la fin de l'année 2023 que les
premiers véhicules seraient disponibles
en 2024 donc de ce point de vue ça n'a
pas changé le nombre de véhicule il est
fonction de la restriction à l'Union
européenne des constructeurs automobiles
éligibles et les le nombre de véhicules
qui le sera sera très bientôt présenté
il y aura évidemment plusieurs types de
véhicules
disponibles notre chiffre pour 2024 il
est pas fonction d'un engagement
budgétaire mais de la disponibilité des
véhicules je le redis dans les
discussions qui ont été conduites avec
les Lou
et je vous confirme le chiffre de 100 €
et j'en profite quand même pour indiquer
la chose
suivante 100 € c'est le montant moyen
d'un
plein donc le calcul par rapport à une
viture thermique est vite
fait l'éligibilité vous la connaissez
sur les déciles reste si nous sommes
victimes de notre succès de savoir
comment on
priorise on peut pas prioriser par
métier ce serait à la fois très complexe
et potentiellement à l'intérieur des
mêmes métiers vous pouvez avoir des
écarts de revenus ou à l'échelle du
couple ou à l'échelle de la
personne nous regardons et ça fait
partie des sujets qui doivent être
tranchés si effectivement une sorte de
priorisation territoriale peut avoir
lieu il y a plusieurs
écoles celle dont je me réclame consiste
à dire qu'il faut à la fois des
territoires ruraux sur lesquels il y a
pas d'alternative pour les voitures et
les ZFE de manière à apporter des
réponses là où on a cette contrainte et
en
parallèle démontrer que là où on mettra
pas des transports en commun parce que
il n'y aurait pas de rentabilité
écologique à faire circuler des cars
vides sur des routes nous avons à
développer un modèle alternatif à la
voiture thermique les précisions
arrivent mais je vous assure qu'on est
exactement dans les pur de ce qui a été
indiqué je vais terminer par ZFE comme
ça je ferai le lien et donc j'arrive sur
l'inter opérabilité des bandes de
recharge dans ce
domaine un certain nombre de décrets
successifs ont été pris le standard
initial c'est le standard de la
directive AFFID de 2014 qui a été
modifié en 2021 par un décret qui a
permis de
d'ajouter des dispositifs d'amende
administrative pour les opérateurs qui
ne rendent pas leur bornes interopérabl
et globalement à la minute où nous nous
parlons entre le texte de 2014 le texte
de 2017 et le texte de la fin de l'année
l'interopérabilité si elle n'est pas
effective peut donner lieu à des amendes
et à des sanctions l'autre sujet c'est
évidemment le plan de déploiement sur
lequel vous ne m'interrogez pas on a
dépassé le million de bornes à domicile
ou au domicile des gens on a dépassé les
100000 accessibles sur l'espace public
et dans le cadre de la planification
écologique nous prévoyons dans les
années qui viennent que ce chiffre soit
multiplié par 2 puis par 3 puis par 4 au
fur et à mesure que les Français font le
choix de cette électrification et je me
permets de vous renvoyer au chiffres
mensuels
d'immatriculation le dernier mois connu
nous avons dépassé les 19 % le mois
d'avant c'était 18 la moyenne de l'année
précédente c'était 13 preuve que malgré
certains discours qui remettent en cause
du bien fondé de cette trajectoire nous
sommes en pleinedans et preuve de la
nécessité d'accompagner nos
constructeurs pour qu'il se fasse pas
déborder par ceux qui seraient déjà en
train d'innover là-dessus sur les
ZFE plusieurs plusieurs éléments
d'abord non seulement philippe Tabarot
m'a privé du plaisir de citer son
rapport mais il est lui à la différence
d'une partie de ce que j'ai cité presque
sur ma table de chevet parce que j'ai
bien conscience que le sujet n'est pas
encore totalement derrière nous
laissez-moi vous répondre dans quelques
minutes je n'ai pas fait de
communication j'ai fait j'ai rappeler ce
qui était le droit à la minute où nous
nous parlons il n'y a pas 43
agglomération de plus de 150000
habitants qui vont interdire les
critères 5 les critères 4 et les
critères 3 il y a 43 agglomération qui
doivent mettre en place une zone à
faible émission sauf si au cours des 5
dernières années ils en ont eu trois
dans lesquelles ils sont en dessous des
seuils et ils peuvent à ce moment-là
demander une exonération à la mise en
place du dispositif c'est la loi que
vous avez voté et pour ceux qui ne le
feraient pas la seule obligation est
d'interdire les véhicules non
classés au 1er janvier de la mise en
place de leur ZFE c'estàdire 0,5% du
parc c'est
tout dans les autres territoires les C
qui sont en dépassement de seuil qui ont
été rappelés par Philippe Tabar Paris
Lyon Marseille Strasbourg et Ran eux
sont tenus un calendrier contraignant
même si Strasbourg pourrait sortir de ce
panel dans le courant de l'année qui
arrive si les résultat de la qualité de
l'air se
confirm c'est tellement
vrai je vais pas aller
là-dedans bref
euh Toulouse reins un certain nombre de
territoires ont d'ailleurs indiqué qu'il
renonçaient à des mesures plus
contraignantes au 1er janvier prochain
compte tenu du fait qu'ils étaient
territoires de vigilance et pas et des
feux euh des facto ce qui démontre le
bien fondé de ce rappel et le fait que
le risque d'exclusion pointé par
certains n'aura pas lieu je précise que
l'enjeu reste bien depuis le début un
enjeu de santé publique et que de ce
point V on devrait collectivement se
réjouir d'avoir plutôt moins de
territoires concernés parce que c'est la
preuve qu'on a une diminution des
particules fil et des NOx maintenant
pour qu'une ZFE existe il faut
effectivement qu'elle soit effective
pour qu'elle soit effective il faut
qu'il puisse y avoir des contrôles dans
le PLF qui vous est soumis il y a quand
même un principe qui est la rétrocession
intégrale des amendes au territoires qui
mettront en place ces radars moi
j'assume une vision totalement
décentralisée du sujet les collectivités
déterminent le nombre de radars qu'elles
souhaitent elles encaissent les produits
de ces amendes nous avons dans le cadre
du fond vert des dispositifs d'appui aux
collectivités territoriales qui ont
conduit à donner des millions d'euros au
collectivités qui sont d'ors et déjà
soumises à ces dispositifs de ZFE qui
ont pu toucher pour certaines jusqu'à 6
millions d'euros pour accompagner la
mise en place d'une partie des
dispositifs donc qu'on ne me dise pas
que l'État n'accompagne pas ça fait
partie des mesures classiques sur
lesquelles on se tient à votre
disposition pour vous donner les
chiffres précis de consommation à ce
titre ensuite on a le problème de
l'homologation des
radars puisque que sur le plan du
principe les choses sont simples
l'homologation est nettement plus
complexe qu'il n'y paraît parce que vous
avez des critères techniques qui entrent
en ligne de compte notamment sur le fait
de savoir si on est sur la lecture des
plaques d'immatriculation mais sur la
reconnaissance globalement du type de
véhicule pour emporter le fait de savoir
si il est probable qu'il soit critère 5
critère 4 ou critère 3 donc sur la façon
de le faire ce qui nécessite beaucoup
d'aller-retours technique compris sur
les marges d'erreurs qui sont
acceptables et on est bien sur un
problème qui est à la frontière du
technique et du juridique et sur un
travail dont on peut veut dire qu'il n'a
pas commencé avec le vote de la loi mais
plutôt à l'été 2022 ce qui fait que
c'est en 2024 que nous aurons les
débouchés mais que je ne vois pas
comment on aura un déploiement avant
l'année
2025 il peut arriver que la presse fasse
des approximations et la date de la
mi-novembre était le début à partir
duquel j'étais susceptible selon mon
agenda de pouvoir réunir les uns et les
autres on est pour être tout à fait
honnête sur une période qui s'étend de
la mi-novembre à la mi-décembre et avec
une recherche de date F en particulier
pour réunir les cinq agglomérations qui
sont en mode ZDF et le rapport Pompili
de parangonage qui permet aussi d'aller
regarder comment on fait les 14 pays et
les 270 collectivités qui en Europe ont
mis en place des zones à faible émission
nous renseignent on observe d'ailleurs
que dans certains pays des F sont en
train d'être démontter après atteindre
de la qualité des après atteindre des
résultats espérés en terme de qualité de
l'air je vais pas être beaucoup plus
long et je pense qu'on aura quelques
quelques occasions je veux dire à Martha
cidra
que je ne réponds jamais par
anticipation à la question est-ce que
vous soutiendrez un amendement tant que
je ne l'ai pas vu écrit mais que je veux
lui faire part comp tenu de la
bienveillance avec laquelle j'ai lu son
rapport de la bienveillance avec
laquelle j'examinerai ses amendements et
je propose peut-être un temps de travail
avec un de mes collaborateurs proches
pour qu'on puisse lui faire un retour de
ce que nous pourrons
soutenir je crois énormément à ça et
dans quelques jours je reçois
officiellement le rapport sur la mise en
place d'une TVA 55
sur les produits qui sont précisément
issus du recyclage ou du réemploi ou du
reconditionnement pour qu'on puisse
regarder si c'est pas un levier pour
être capable de pousser je redis ce que
j'ai dit plutôt il faut que l'écologie
elle puisse s'accompagner de gains de
pouvoir d'achat pour que ce qui est bon
pour la planète et des emplois locaux
serve ça c'est un demi million d'emplois
d'ors et déjà l'économie circulaire dans
notre
pays et c'est un chiffre qui progresse
tous les ans et qui va être accompagné
au travers des bonus mais je crois des
dispositifs de tarification incitative
sur la consigne vous avez pleinement
compris et je suis hyper cont endre
votre question si j'avais eu à susciter
une question d'un sénateur ou du
sénatrice j'aurais suscité celle-là j'ai
dit de façon extrêmement claire aux
assises de Nantes que nous ne pouvions
pas partir d'un taux moyen national de
62 % de recyclage sur les bouteilles en
plastique pour en déduire qu'on était
obligé de généraliser la consigne parce
que en vrai on varie de 40 à 90 % en
fonction des
territoir qu' motif qu'on a des
territoires qui viennent tout juste au
1er janvier de cette année de lancer la
collecte sélective en porte à porte de
généraliser les consignes d'extension du
tri prétendre que la mauvaise moyenne
qui est la nôre devrait conduire à
mettre la consigne partout est une
fausse bonne idée parce que nous avons
des effets de bord dans la mise en place
de la
consigne les déconsigneurs seront sur
les parkings et grandes surfaces et
poseront des difficultés au commerce de
centrreville ils donneront l'illusion à
une partie de nos concitoyens que c'est
écolo d'acheter du plastique la preuve
c'est que dans des pays qui sont à 90 %
de recyclage il n'y a pas de baisse de
la production de plastique il y a une
augmentation du nombre de bouteill B qui
sont mises sur le marché pour que ça
fonctionne il faut être aux alentours de
15 centimes par
bouteille augmenter le prix des packs de
1 € dans le contexte dans lequel nous
sommes en se disant que 90 % des sommes
seront récupérées mais ce qui laisse
quand même un delta ne me semblait pas
être un excellent signal à bien des
égards on pénalise les collectivités les
plus vertueuses celles qui ont investi
dans des centres de tri qui ont déjà mis
en place des consignes qui se sont lancé
dans les dispositifs bref en apparence
c'est une bonne idée le jour où on va
soulever le capot pour regarder comment
ça fonctionne on apercevra qu'on est
loin de la réalité telle qu'elle se
présente je viens d'envoyer le cahier
des charges de la Rep emballage il est
fait mention d'une consigne mais de
celle que j'ai évoqué à Nant j'ai dit
quoi j'ai dit si que que nous allions
paramétrer la mise en place de consignes
régionalisé je demande donc dans le
cadre de cette REP qu'on me dise s'il
est possible de mettre en place des
consignes régionales parce que avec 45 %
de taux de consignes pour la totalité de
la région
île-de-fance si demain on est sur des
territoires qui flirtent avec les 90
mais qu'on a une région qui nous plombe
ou un autre territoire qu' le fait je ne
veux pas exclure par anticipation que ça
puiss être la solution là où il n'y a
pas eu suffisamment d'efforts collectifs
notre pays P 1,3 milliards d'euros
d'amende au titre de l'Union européenne
contenu de son mauvais taux de recyclage
800 millions au titre des ménages 500
millions au titre des entreprises vous
avez raison mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que notre intérêt collectif est
quand même de diminuer
donc d'améliorer notre taux et il n'est
pas logique que des territoires qui sont
à 90 % paient au travers de leurs impôts
nationaux la par qui ne devrait pas
payer si on territorialisait une partie
de cette amende sur la base des
résultats de recyclage et donc de façon
très concrète je souhaite qu'on puisse
poser la question de la façon dont
fonctionnerait une consigne régionalisée
la région île-france étant plus grande
que la Belgique preuve que on peut le
faire à ce type d'échelle je dis pas
qu'on va le faire je dis qu'on a la
nécessité de se poser la question de
comment on fait je su donc cohérent avec
ce que j'ai dit si vous lisez mot à mot
le cahier des charges vous apercevrez
qu'il y a rien d'autre à
l'intérieur très bien merci Monsieur le
Ministre alors dans l'ordre je vais
laisser la parole à marieclaude varias
merci à vous elle est là je suis là
renandc et Jean ivrou alors très court
s'il vous plaît pour avoir le temps de
d'avoir la
réponse on pardon on fera une question
de
réponse une question une réponse
monsieur le ministre les territoires
ruraux vous le savez représente 90 % des
communes françaises et ce sont à nen pas
douter des acteurs des acteurs in
contournable de la transition écologique
parce qu'il dispose des ressources
naturelles l'eau l'air les produits
agricoles et forestiers en fait tous les
ingrédients de l'industrie verte à
travers le plan France ruralité je ne
doute pas de votre volonté d'apporter un
début de réponse aux ma ruraux qui ont
vu disparaître leurs services publics
leurs médecins et quelquefois les
quelques industries qui qui leur resta
avec la baisse d'attractivité qui en
résulte alors même euh si l'enveloppe de
90 millions d'euros dédié à ce programme
France ruralité nous apparaît
insuffisante les quelques mesures
envisagées apparaissent positives comme
la valorisation des AM aménités rurales
à travers une dotation dédiée notamment
à la protection de la biodiversité le
programme village d'avenir à condition
que ce programme village d'avenir bien
sûr couvre plus de 500 communes il y
aura peut-être une autre jauge derrière
ces 500 et que par ailleurs au-delà de
l'ingénierie
euh mise à disposition des communes les
projets puissent être aidés
financièrement et à cet égard j'aimerais
que vous puissiez me répondre parce que
l'ingénierrie c'est bien mais derrière
il faut financer les investissements
s'agissant du fond vert bien sûr c'est
positif qu'il soit porté à 2 millards
500 millions pour autant si la Haus et
moyen dédié à la transition écologique
est à saluer son financement euh bien
évidemment ne peut pas se faire au
détriment d'autres lignes abondant les
budgets locaux c'est une préoccupation
chez les élus et si on veut qu'il
s'engage à mon avis il faut tenir compte
de cela le Comité des finances locales
dénonce la suppression progressive de la
CVAE et dit même que c'est comme un
holdup c'est pour eux un holdup destiné
à financer le fond vert je prends acte
une récente étude publié le 7 novembre
par l'Institut de l'économie pour le
climat détaille quatre scénaris destinés
à financer l'accélération des
investissements climat des collectivités
à l'horizon 2030 il y en a un qui me
plaît un peu plus que les autres le
scénario appelé état se fonde sur une
augmentation du soutien de l'État
précisément par une indexation de la DGF
sur l'inflation et par la pérenisation
du fond vert au-delà de 2024 à 2
milliards 500 millions voilà qui serait
de nature à motiver nos élus je voudrais
savoir ce que vous en pensez en tout cas
moi je pense que ce serait de nature
enfin pour terminer Monsieur le ma
simplement monsieur le ministre j'en ai
pour une minute je souhaite par ailleurs
attirer votre attention sur la
multiplication des phénomènes de
catastroph naturell parce que je suis
très concernée en Dordogne et comme dans
d'autres départements j'avais déposé un
amendement l'année dernière qui n'a pas
été retenu et 200 millions me semble
insuffisant prévu au PLF très bien merci
Monsieur ministre très
bien
ingénierie financement de la transition
écologique catastrophe naturelle et
accompagnement vous faites bien de citer
l'Institut pour le
climat pizanifer c'est 68 milliards et
Madame malfous c'est 68 milliards de
besoins dans ces 68 c'est entre 30 et 33
pour la part publique dans ces 30 à 33
c'est une vingtaine de milliards pour la
part état et une dizaine de milliards
pour la part collectivité territoriale
avec 2,5 milliards nous faisons 12,5
milliards d'euros d'investissement pour
le climat on est dans les pures du
besoin défini par I forc sujet c'est
est-ce que les estimations sont justes
et globalement je le dis aussi j'ai
commencé en vous parlant du coup de
l'inetion il faut bien mesurer que dans
un certain nombre de cas c'est aussi une
philosophie qui consiste à faire bien
pour avoir à éviter d'y revenir et de
mesurer qu'une partie des
investissements pour le climat à la
différence de d'autres sont porteurs
d'économie de fonctionnement et donc il
y a une une vertu pas seulement
écologique mais potentiellement
budgétaire les 2 milliards et demi ils
sont sanctuarisés ils le sont jusqu'à la
fin la DGF éternel débat j'observe que à
la minute où n nous parlons des
gouvernements de droite et de gauche au
cours de ces dernières années ont ù mis
fin l'indexation ou ponctionner dans des
proportions importantes les moyens des
collectivités que pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans nous avons relever les
niveaux de DGF l'année dernière certes
que de 320 mais je vous rappelle qu'on
était à zéro les années précédentes un
nouvel effort cette année et que je ne
peux pas préjuger de ce qui se passera
ma conviction la plus la plus forte
c'est que la DGF est en bout de souffle
c'est que quand quand vous avez une
dotation qui repose sur un nombre de
kilomètres de voirie alors que dans une
partie des territoires ça a été doté aux
intercommunalités quand vous ne reposez
que sur les personnes alors qu'il faut
tenir compte des territoires quand vous
avez des DSU et des DSR qui se croisent
en fonction des fusions de communes on a
besoin d'assiste de la fiscalité locale
et de repenser un panier qui se gère de
manière différente sur le plan des
subventions c'est ma conviction
personnelle enfin le holdup sur la CVAE
c'est une escroquerie intellectuelle
pardon de vous le dire de cette manière
la CVE est compensée via la TVA donc
qu'on aille dire que on compense une une
dép une recette et qu'en plus on ajoute
une subvention ça fait un solde pour
l'État qui est de la totalité du montant
de la CVE auquel vous ajoutez le montant
du fond vert et écoutez le silence des
régions qui sont les premières
bénéficiaires de fraction de TVA leur
silence l'année dernière est lié au fait
que quand vous avez une inflation de 9 %
ça veut dire que vous avez une
progression des crédits de TVA de 9 % la
moyenne de la hausse du rendement de la
TVA est supérieure à celle de la CVAE en
moyenne d'un point au cours de ces
dernières années ça a un inconvénient
majeur c'est qu'un territoire qui fait
plus que les autres pour la
réindustrialisation ne touche pas
totalement son bonus mais sur la moyenne
des soutiens aux collectivités
territoriales je vous le dis comme je le
pense on est sur une recette dynamique
enfin sur les catastrophes
naturelles notre système là aussi est à
bout de soufle nous ne pouvons pas
continuer à gérer avec une CCR dotée de
3 milliards d'euros
11 millions de personnes qui sont
potentiellement concernées par le
retraitgonflement d'argile des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui sont
concernées par l'érosion du trait de
côte l'augmentation des risques
éboulements et donc dans le plan
d'adaptation d'une France à 4 degr dans
la manière de se prémunir il faudra
qu'on fasse bouger nos critères de
catastrophe naturell et nos modes de
solidarité parce qu'en plus on va avoir
des assureur se retirer d'un certain
nombre de marchés contre les aléas
climatiques compte tenu de l'ampleur de
ce que ça pourrait écouter donc on a un
effort de conception et de refondte sur
lequel pas seulement pour la Dordogne
madame la sénatrice je vous donne
totalement crédit de la nécessité
d'ouvrir ce chantier nous le menons pour
le moment en interne on le fera
évidemment sous le contrôle de la
commission spéciale présidée par Ronal
ANC puis sous le contrôle du Parlement
en début d'année prochaine très bienci
monsieur le ministre Renand oui merci
monsieur le Président alors il faut
imaginer siisif heureux mais dans le cas
présent j'ai le sentiment qu'on est plus
très loin du moment où on va réussir a
coincé le rocher sur le haut de la
colline euh je je reprends ce qu'a dit
euh de manière très opportune
Pierre-Jean de Nicolaï sur le fait que
donc la Cour des comptes a bien dit que
le crte ne jouait pas son rôle
intégrateur que le point 5 nous en avons
parlé tout à l'heure au café euh du
nouveau rapport du Sénat parle bien du
fait qu'il faut une dotation socle pour
les crte en fait on est en train de se
rapprocher de ce qu'on plébiscite au
Sénat depuis des années c'était une
dotation de fonctionnement socle climat
ou transition on a élargi depuis à à la
biodiversité donc ma question monsieur
le ministre est extrêmement précise si
nous mettons un amendement pour prendre
600 millions c'était la somme pour les
interc 600 millions du fond vert pour
une dotation socle pour les inter donc
c'est c'est à somme constante qui
permettra en plus de reprendre ça a été
dit les 60 millions de villages d'avenir
qui sont encore qui ont été mal reçu sur
mon territoire on a eu le cas puisque le
territoire Châteaubriant a reçu on sait
une partie des commun dises mais on peut
pas comment c'est alors que village
d'anenir dit bien qu'on a un problème de
fonctionnement et d'ingénierie donc on
arrive aux même conclusions on pourrait
réintégrer dedans le côe le le contrat
d'objectif territorial de l'ADEN qui qui
donne de bons résultats par ailleurs
donc on y est
allons-y mettons cette dotation socle
avec peut-être des objectifs puisque on
n' pas réglé encore cette ce rôle de
cont contrat intégrateur du crte c'est
pas nous qui le disons et je pense que
on y est prêt donc voilà notre
proposition est simple à un financement
constant on met enfin cette dotation
socle dont on a besoin pour mettre en
cohérence les les politiques publiques
territoriales maintenant que tout le
monde a compris que sans ces politiques
publi territorial on n arrivera pas donc
première question extrêmement précise
deuxième question qui vient de
l'Assemblée nationale et très rapidement
je le
sais on a le toujours le débat sur le
fait de de sortir une partie de
l'investissement de transition du calcul
classique de l'endettement des
collectivités cette question est
d'autant plus prignante parce qu'il y a
un point dont on a pas parlé mais qui
réimpacte fortement les capacités de
transition c'est l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt qui qui change profondément
les temps de retour sur investissement
par exemple sur la trans sur
l'efficacité énergétique pour les
collectivités or l'assemblée a ouvert
lors du
débat sur sur le sur le PLF cette
question d'avoir une forme de
comptabilisation ça n'empêche pas qu'il
faudra les rembourser une force de
comptabilisation spécifique pour les
pour les investissements de transition
des territoire donc est-ce que vous êtes
ouvert au fait qu'au Sénat on remette ce
qui a été ouvert par l'Assemblée
nationale donc deux questions
extrêmement précises je ne serai pas
plus long puisque nous n'avons pas le
temps mais mon collègue jaces ferern que
je remercie reviendra en séance sur la
question stockamine qui est aussi dans
le budget très bien onattend avec
impatience monsieur le ministre det
verte je dois des excuses à marieaude
Var parce que je pas répondu sur village
d'avenir et donc je remercie ronandtec
d'avoir relancé vous avez tout à fait
raison on est sur une première
génération on va évidemment regarder
avec la NCT le nombre de demandes que
nous avons je pour être totalement
honnête et transparent avec vous j'ai
pas à titre personnel poursuivi ou
piloter le montant de ce qui était la
première marche et le nombre de ceux qui
seraient labellisés je me permets quand
même de vous dire que les
crédits par définition il visent à
accompagner du service fait et donc du
service fait fait que sur une année de
lancement même si vous lancez des
dépenses le moment où vous pouvez les
justifier les constater et faire en
sorte de les payer fait que vous avez
toujours un retard à l'allumage sur les
dispositifs et donc il faut pas se baser
sur la somme qui est inscrite au budget
2024 pour dimensionner le nombre de ceux
qui pourrai t accompagn je pourrais pas
vous dire la même chose dans un
an il va falloir continuer à porter un
peu le rocher monsieur dantech pour une
raison
simple dire que je prends 600 millions
sur un fond vert qui représente 2
milliards et demi qui correspond
globalement besoin de soutien
l'investissement dans un contexte que
nous avons décrit pour aller le mettre
sur du fonctionnement je n'y suis pas
favorable à la minute où nous parlons
pour trois
raisons la première c'est que nous
venons de lancer des cops territoriales
qui visent à ce que pour le milieu de
l'année prochaine nous ayons précisément
la somme des demandes des collectivités
correspondant à leur besoins de
planification pourquoi le mois de juin
parce qu'on commence le budget de l'État
en
juillet que quelque chose me dit que la
demande que vous portez pourrait émaner
de ces trajectoires
territoriales la là ou pour l'année qui
arrive le fait que nous ayons reçu 18000
demandes 18000 demandes de subvention
dans le cadre du fond vert fait que
après en avoir satisfait 8000 je suis
plutôt satisfait que nous puissions nous
dire qu'on va pouvoir accompagner celle
qu'on a pas pu prendre cette année au
titre de l'année qui arrive avec en
particulier le lancement et
l'enclenchement d'un plan pour les
écoles qui est absolument crucial aussi
bien en efficacité énergétique qu'en
conséquence pour les collectivités
territoriales puisque dans la
quasittalité des communes de ce pays
l'école est le premier bâtiment en terme
de consommation énergétique et donc la
première source de
dépenses
enfin le sujet c'est celui de la maille
est-ce qu'on est sur les interc il y a
des débats aujourd'hui multiples que
vous n'ignorez pas avec dans certains
cas le fait de considérer
que la commune doit pouvoir être
responsabilisée et pas disparaître du
dispositif dans d'autres l'interrogation
sur ce qu'est le rôle du département
pour être
l'assemblier du dispositif dans un trè
des bassins de vie qui peuvent prendre
la forme de pcaet qui pourrai nécessiter
des appuis et je me souviens y compris
discussion précédente que nous avions eu
sur cette dotation climat donc la vérité
m'oblige à vous dire que je ne donnerai
pas un avis favorable à ce qu'on prenne
600 millions d'euros du fond vert pour
en faire une dotation de fonctionnement
qui viennent amplifier la hausse des
moyens de fonctionnement des
collectivités au titre de l'année 2024
que la réflexion sur le bon
accompagnement des collectivités sera au
cœur de la suite des COP
territoriales
det ver ah la dette
verte je suis totalement favorable j'ai
personnellement défendu ce principe au
moment de nos débats sur le tir
financement en disant que il fallait de
toute façon qu'on soit
capable non pas de faire de l'habillage
de bilan mais de distinguer la dette qui
nous permet d'éviter des dépenses de
fonctionnement et de faire face au cout
de l'inaction et le premier étage c'est
le budget vert et je voudrais
avec peut-être une toute petite pointe
d'émotion dire que la notre pays a perdu
un Grandmaire qui était le président de
la commission des finances de la MF qui
a été emporté par une maladie il y a un
peu plus d'un mois pierre bretau qui
portait ses questions financières et qui
a été emporté par un cancer il y a tout
juste un mois qui a emporté un vote
favorable de la MF sur la mise en place
de budget vert pour les communes de plus
de 3500 habitants lors de la dernière
commission qu'il a
présidé donc c'est pas sans une certaine
émotion que je je pense que là on aura
l'outil de dialogue qui permettra déjà
en disant ce qui est vert de commencer
ensuite à pouvoir potentiellement
comptabiliser dans les trajectoires
d'investissement et donc c'est un socle
utile qui est dans le PLF qui vous est
proposé dans la copie initiale avec
l'accord de la
MF et enfin très bien merci ministre
jeanou j'auris qu'une question monsieur
le ministre vous inquiétez pas juste une
question sur la compétence gmapi que je
voulais vous poser par rapport donc n
vous savez savez nous sommes
quelques-uns depuis des années à avoir
alerté sur l'inadéquation de ressources
mobilisées pour l'exercice de la
compétence gmapi le ministre et député
Joel girud a déposé un amendement au PLF
pour 2024 sollicitant un rapport
parlementaire dans les 6 mois jugeant
d'une opportunité d'introduire une
solidarité à mon Enval pour l'exercice
de cette compétence la mission
d'information sur la politique de l'eau
de nos collègues po TR et gilet propose
d'introduire une fraction de la taxe
gmapi mutualisée sur l'ensemble des
bassins versant pour je cite soutenir
les actions au titre de la gmapie des
EPCI disposant de peu de ressources et
de l linéaire à proposer voilà je
voulais avoir un peu votre avis
là-dessus s'il y a eu une réflexion pour
apporter un peu des financements
complémentaires car dans mon département
les Alb Provence on a des petites
communautés de commune de 11000
habitants ils ont fait une étude pour la
protection des inondations ils ont un
coût de travaux de 15 millions d'euros
et avec les recettes à 40 € par habitant
ils arrivent à peine à 1 million d'euros
voilà merci monsieur le ministre de
votre réponse rapide ouis merci j'
j'invite les collègues qui n'ont pas pu
poser leurs questions et je je le
regrette euh de de le faire par écrit et
je pense que le ministre va s'engager à
à y répondre très bien je je voudrais
d'abord vous remercier du temps que vous
m'avez consacré et vous dire que je suis
confus l'année dernière j'ai on m'a
rapporté que j'étais resté jusqu'à la
dernière question un peu plus de 2h40
cette année les difficultés d'agenda
faut que je ne peux pas euh me dérober
par rapport à ce qui m'attend à 18h30 et
sans vous dire de quoi il s'agit je
préférais rester avec vous c'est vous
dire à quel point euh
bref donc non tout ça tout ça pour vous
dire les choses
suivante j'ai maapis ça me ça m'inspire
deux réflexions la première c'est qu'on
on est dans un pays formidable où c'est
dans les 3 mois qui précèdent la mise en
œuvre d'une modification législative
annoncée il y a 10 ans que tout le monde
se réveille je vous rappelle que c'est
un texte de 2014 qui prévoit que c'est
en 2024 que la compétence sera plin anné
entière et ça me rappelle avec
amertume la loi sur l'accessibilité
universelle ou d'autres sujets sur
lequel tout le monde est d'accord et
puis tout à coup quand on se retrouve au
moment où ça arrive on explique que les
choses sont
complexes et et je le dis en mesurant
aussi que même l'État a plutôt
intensifié son travail au cours de ces
derniers mois là où des questions
avaient été posées un peu plus tôt et
c'est un sujet que je connais un peu
pour avoir été dans une ancienne vie
président d'une communauté urbaine
concerné par une grande façade sur la
Loire et sur des dig de Manial qui sont
encore une difficultés particulières à
l'intérieur de la gmapi nous voyons d'un
très bon œil la solidarité à mon aval
j'ai fait personnellement sauter la
condition qui obligeait à lever la taxe
pour pouvoir demander du fond vert pour
accompagner des crédits de travaux et ce
sera officiel dans le guide qui sera
présenté l'année prochaine je le dis
parce que l'argument selon lequel on
exigeait que les gens ayent lever
l'impôt pour ensuite demander une
subvention moi je considère qu'il y a
une forme de liberté de gestion qui fait
que si certains souhaitent concentrer
des subventions pour faire quelque chose
dans un endroit et dans d'autres
l'appliquer de manière différente il
faut qu'on laisse cette souplesse et
puis on a potentiellement des
dispositifs au tytre de Barnier qui sont
également mobilisable en vrai je pense
qu'on y verra aussi plus clair dans
quelques mois entre ceux qui disent qui
redoutent ceux qui se sont déjà très
bien organisés qu'on mis en place les
dispositifs et ceux qui s'organisent
avec des solidarités qui n'attendent pas
de règles je prends un exemple chez moi
on a considéré qu'il fallait pas se
baser seulement sur le linéaire de
façade mais qu'il fallait qu'on tienne
compte du nombre d'habitants des
intercommunalités et qu'on pouvait
corriger le linéaire de façade pour que
là où il y avait beaucoup d'habitants il
payent un peu plus que là où il y avait
peu d'habitants sur un grand linéaire de
façade que ça permettait de mettre en
place une solidarité effective donc on
va avoir des retours très bientôt mais
solidarité à mon aval oui et mise en
place d'un fond vert qui soit pas
conditionné à la taxe la réponse est oui
aussi même si vous m'avez pas posé la
question c'est ma
réponse merci infiniment et et à très
bientôt parce que je crois qu'après on
va faire le truc pour de vrai dans
l'hémicycle à un moment sur ces
différents sujets merci monsieur
ministre merci chers
collègu pres c'est parfait